depuis le début de l'épidémie les
décisions du gouvernement sont appuyés
sur l'expertisé de scientifiques
pouvez-vous nous communiquer l'avis
scientifique qui indique la pertinence
d'une réouverture des établissements
scolaires
le 11 mai prochain pouvez vous nous dire
quels seront les enfants prioritairement
inviter à aller à l'école puisque vous
avez indiqué que cette reprise ne serait
ni simultanée ni obligatoire
pouvez vous nous dire quel matériel et
en quelles quantités seront mis à
disposition des personnels de
l'éducation nationale comme des agents
territoriaux
les soignants manque encore de tout
aujourd'hui c'est très inquiétant
quelles consignes et quels moyens seront
donnés aux collectivités pour assurer
l'entretien ou la la désinfection
régulière par exemple des locaux devront
elles assuré la restauration ou le
transport scolaire
quelles stratégies de tests est prévue
il semble que les enfants et les jeunes
soient des porteurs asymptomatiques du
coc vide 19
si l'on veut donc enrayer efficacement
l'épidémie il paraît indispensable de
les dépister tout comme le personnel
enseignant
tout semble indiqué monsieur le ministre
que la date du 11 mai a été annoncée
sans que ses questions étaient été
examinées ce sont pourtant ces réponses
que les français attendent pour vous
répondre
la parole est aux milices de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur
jean michel blanquer revêt la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs toutes les
questions que vous avez posées sont
évidemment importantes et c'est
justement ces questions que nous
traitons actuellement que nous avons
traité aussi en préparant le
déconfinement et vous seriez la première
à vous étonner si nous les traitions
verticalement depuis le gouvernement
sans concertation c'est donc à la fois
en consultant les autorités de santé
mais aussi en discutant avec les
organisations syndicales avec les
représentants des associations d'élus à
mf adf arf
mais aussi avec les fédérations de
parents d'élèves avec les représentants
des lycéens
bref toutes les parties prenantes du
sujet scolaire que nous avançons bien
entendu le
la vision qu'on doit avoir lé mondial
aussi elle est internationale et
européenne
nous faisons beaucoup de comparaisons
européennes et il y a plusieurs pays qui
ont déjà commencé a décidé le
déconfinement et nous regardons avec
beaucoup d'attention
leur stratégie de déconfinement le mot
clé vous le savez il a été prononcé par
le président de la république c'est le
mot de progressivité ce mot de
progressivité signifie que le 11 mai
vous n'aurez pas un fonctionnement
normal des écoles des collèges et des
lycées comme si de rien n'était c'est
tout le contraire et nous avons été très
clair depuis le début
cela va être progressive cela signifie
que vous n'aurez pas tous les élèves
tout de suite ça signifie que nous
agirons à la lumière des principes qui
ont été affichées par le président la
république c'est à dire profondément la
lumière d'un principe qui ne devrait pas
vous choquer c'est à dire le principe
social
si nous faisons tout cela c'est pour des
raisons sociales si nous ne finissons
pas le confinement suffisamment tôt il y
aura des désastres sociaux pour les
élèves les plus éloignés de l'école
c'est ce point là auquel vous devriez
être très sensible aussi mais bien
entendu nous allons veiller à la
sécurité sanitaire de tous c'est notre
premier principe aussi bien pour les
professeurs que pour les élèves et ça
passe par la réponse aux différentes
questions que vous avez posé à quelques
autres aussi d'ailleurs
par exemple ce le travail avec les
collectivités locales sur les
équipements sur le nettoyage avant
l'arrivée des élèves sur l'éventuelle
port du masque etc
tout ceci est travaillée et vous aurez
toutes vos réponses lorsque le premier
ministre exposera le plan général dans
moins de deux semaines je vous remercie
tous que la concertation ne s'engagent
qu'à après l'annnonce de la date ça
c'est la première chose que je voudrais
dire
la deuxième chose c'est que les français
ne sont pas dupes des valeurs que vous
hurter parce que oui le confinement
aggrave les inégalités sociales je fais
partie de ceux qui devaient dès le début
ont alerté là dessus mais si on veut
répondre à cette question là alors comme
je voulais proposer
il faut empêcher annuler les fermetures
de classes en éducation prioritaire à la
prochaine rentrée
il faut doter nos collèges et nos lycées
de postes supplémentaires alors que
certains sont supprimés voilà comment on
résoudra les inégalités sociales dans
l'école jeu